A présent je vais vous raconter une histoire.
C'est une histoire indienne à propos d'une Indienne et de son parcours.
Laissez-moi commencer en parlant de mes parents.
Je suis le résultat de
cette mère et ce père visionnaires.
Il y a plusieurs années, lorsque je suis née dans les années 1950 --
les années 1950 et 1960
n'appartenaient pas aux filles en Inde.
Elles appartenaient aux garçons.
Elles appartenaient aux garçons destinés aux affaires
et qui hériteraient de l'affaire de leurs parents.
Et les filles se pomponneraient pour se marier.
Ma famille, dans ma ville --
et presque dans le pays -- était unique.
Nous étions quatre, pas un,
et heureusement sans garçons.
Nous étions quatre filles et pas de garçons.
Et mes parents faisaient partie
d'une famille de propriétaires terriens.
Mon père défia son propre grand-père,
presque jusqu'au déshéritement,
parce qu'il décida d'éduquer
ses quatre enfants.
Il nous envoya dans l'une des meilleures écoles de la ville
et nous donna la meilleure éducation.
Comme je disais : quand nous naissons, nous ne choisissons pas nos parents.
Et quand nous allons à l'école, nous ne choisissons pas notre école.
Les enfants ne choisissent pas une école,
ils obtiennent seulement l'école choisie par les parents.
Donc voilà l'époque fondatrice pour moi.
J'ai grandi comme cela, ainsi que mes trois sœurs.
Et mon père avait l'habitude de dire à cette époque,
"Je vais éparpiller mes quatre filles aux quatre coins du monde."
Je ne sais pas s'il le voulait vraiment, mais c'est arrivé.
Je suis la dernière à être restée en Inde.
L'une est en Grande-Bretagne, une autre est en Amérique
et la dernière est au Canada.
Donc nous sommes toutes les quatre aux quatre coins du monde.
Et comme j'ai dit qu'ils étaient des modèles pour moi,
j'ai suivi deux principes que mon père et ma mère m'ont inculqués.
Le premier, comme ils disaient, "La vie est sur une pente;
soit tu montes,
soit tu descends."
Et le second, qui ne m'a pas quitté,
qui est devenu ma philosophie de vie,
qui a fait toute la différence,
c'est que cent choses surviennent dans votre vie, bonnes ou mauvaises.
Sur 100, 90 sont de votre création.
Elles sont bonnes. Elles sont votre création. Savourez-les.
Si elles sont mauvaises, c'est votre création. Tirez-en des leçons.
10 d'entre elles sont dues à la providence sur laquelle vous ne pouvez agir.
C'est comme la mort d'un membre de la famille,
un cyclone, un ouragan, ou un tremblement de terre.
Vous ne pouvez rien y faire.
Vous devez juste réagir à la situation.
Mais cette réaction provient des 90 pour cent.
Puisque je suis le résultat de cette philosophie,
du 90/10,
et d'autre part, la vie est sur une pente,
c'est la manière dont j'ai été élevée --
à apprécier ce qui m'est donné.
Je suis le fruit d'occasions,
de rares occasions datant des années 1950 et 1960,
que les petites filles n'obtenaient pas.
Et j'étais consciente que ce que mes parents me donnaient
était quelque chose d'unique.
Parce que toutes mes meilleures amies d'école se faisaient belles
pour se marier avec une grosse dot,
et moi j'avais une raquette de tennis et j'allais à l'école
et je faisais toute sorte d'activités parascolaires.
J'ai pensé qu'il fallait que je vous raconte cela.
J'ai dit cela pour poser les bases.
Voilà ce qui suivit.
J'ai rejoint la police indienne en tant que femme robuste,
une femme avec une vigueur inépuisable,
parce que j'avais l'habitude des compétitions de tennis, etc.
Mais j'ai rejoint la police indienne.
Et il s'en suivit une nouvelle façon de maintenir l'ordre.
Pour moi la police représentait le pouvoir de corriger,
le pouvoir d'éviter et le pouvoir de détecter.
C'est une sorte de nouvelle définition de la police jamais introduite en Inde --
le pouvoir d'éviter.
Parce que normalement on disait le pouvoir de détecter, et c'est tout,
ou le pouvoir de punir.
Mais j'ai décidé que non, c'est un pouvoir d'éviter,
car c'est ce que j'ai appris dans mon enfance :
comment éviter les 10 et ne jamais dépasser 10 ?
C'est ainsi que cette notion arriva dans mon service,
et c'était différent de la gestion qu'en faisaient les hommes.
Je ne voulais pas que cela soit différent des hommes, mais ça l'était,
parce que c'était la manière dont j'étais différente.
J'ai redéfini le concept du maintien de l'ordre en Inde.
Je vais vous faire découvrir deux expériences,
mon expérience policière et mon expérience carcérale.
Ce que vous voyez, si vous voyez le titre
dit "La voiture du premier ministre enlevée."
C'était la première fois qu'un premier ministre de l'Inde
recevait une contravention.
(Rires)
C'était la première fois en Inde,
et je peux vous dire que c'était la dernière fois qu'on en entendait parler.
Cela n'arrivera plus jamais en Inde,
parce que c'était pour une fois et pour toujours.
Et c'était comme ça, parce que j'étais sensible,
j'étais compatissante, j'étais très sensible à la justice,
et j'étais pour l'application de la justice.
C'est la raison pour laquelle, en tant que femme, j'ai rejoint la police indienne.
J'avais d'autres possibilités, mais je n'en voulais pas.
Je vais passer à autre chose.
C'est à propos d'une police ferme, d'une police équitable.
J'étais alors connue comme une femme qui ne se laisserait pas faire.
Alors on m'a affectée au hasard à toute sorte de postes,
des postes que d'autres refuseraient.
J'ai été affectée à un poste de policier de prison.
Normalement, les policiers ne veulent pas des prisons.
Ils m'ont envoyée en prison pour m'empêcher d'agir,
pensant qu'il n'y aurait désormais plus de voitures
et plus de personnalités importantes à qui donner des contraventions.
Enfermons-la.
Alors on m'a mutée en prison.
C'était une affectation dans une prison qui était un important repaire de criminels.
Manifestement, ça l'était.
Mais 10 000 personnes,
dont seulement 400 femmes -- 10 000 --
environ 9600
étaient des hommes,
des terroristes, des violeurs,
des voleurs, des voyous --
dont certains que j'avais envoyés en prison
lorsque j'étais policière à l'extérieur.
Alors comment m'en suis-je occupée ?
Le jour de mon arrivée,
je ne savais pas comment les regarder.
J'ai demandé au groupe, "Est-ce que vous priez ?"
Ils me voyaient comme une jeune et petite femme portant un uniforme beige.
J'ai demandé, "Est-ce que vous priez ?"
Et ils n'ont rien dit du tout.
J'ai demandé, "Est-ce que vous priez ? Voulez-vous prier ?"
Ils répondirent, "Oui." Je dis "Très bien, prions."
J'ai prié pour eux, et les choses ont commencé à changer.
Ceci est une image de l'éducation dans la prison.
Les amis, ça n'était jamais arrivé,
que tout le monde étudie dans la prison.
J'ai commencé cela avec le soutien de la communauté.
Le gouvernement n'avait pas de budget.
C'était l'un des plus beaux et des plus grands volontariat
de toutes les prisons du monde.
Cela a été initié dans une prison de Delhi.
Vous voyez un exemple
d'un prisonnier faisant cours à une classe.
Il y a des centaines de classes.
De 9h à 11h, chaque prisonnier participait au programme d'éducation --
le même repaire dans lequel ils pensaient
qu'ils me mettraient derrière les barreaux et que les choses seraient oubliées.
Nous en avons fait un ashram --
d'une prison à un ashram via l'éducation.
Je pense que c'est le plus gros changement.
C'était le début d'un changement.
Les enseignants étaient des prisonniers. Les enseignants étaient bénévoles.
Les manuels scolaires étaient donnés.
Le papier était donné.
Tout était donné,
car il n'y avait pas de budget dédié à l'éducation dans les prisons.
Maintenant si je n'avais pas fait cela,
ce serait un enfer.
C'est la seconde étape.
Je veux vous montrer des moments historiques de mon aventure,
que vous ne verrez probablement jamais ailleurs dans le monde.
Premièrement, les nombres que vous ne verrez jamais.
Deuxièmement, ce concept.
C'est un programme de méditation dans la prison
comprenant plus d'un millier de prisonniers.
1000 prisonniers qui se posaient pour méditer.
C'était l'une des mesures les plus courageuses
que j'ai prise en tant que directrice de la prison.
Et c'est ce qui a changé.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus à ce sujet,
allez voir ce film, "Doing Time Doing Vipassana."
Vous en entendrez parler, et vous allez adorer.
Et écrivez-moi sur KiranBedi.com,
et je vous répondrai.
Laissez-moi vous présenter la diapositive suivante.
J'ai pris le même concept de la conscience.
Car, pourquoi avoir introduit la méditation dans les prisons indiennes ?
Parce que le crime est le résultat d'un esprit déformé.
C'était la déformation de l'esprit qui devait être abordée pour contrôler,
pas par le sermon, pas par le récit,
pas par la lecture, mais en faisant appel à l'esprit.
J'ai porté les mêmes idées au sein de la police,
car les policiers étaient aussi prisonniers de leur esprit,
ils avaient l'impression d'être à part,
et que les gens ne coopéraient pas.
Cela a fonctionné.
C'est une boîte pour les commentaires appelée la boîte à requêtes.
C'est un concept que j'ai introduit
pour écouter les réclamations et les plaintes.
C'était une boîte magique.
C'est une boîte avec une sensibilité.
Voici le dessin d'un prisonnier sur ce qu'il ressentait en prison.
Si vous voyez quelqu'un en bleu --
oui, ce type --
c'était un prisonnier, et c'était un enseignant.
Vous voyez, tout le monde est occupé ; il n'y avait pas de temps à perdre.
Laissez-moi conclure.
Je fais actuellement partie de mouvements,
des mouvements d'éducation
pour les enfants défavorisés,
ils sont des milliers -- En Inde, tout est question de milliers.
D'autre part, dans un mouvement contre la corruption en Inde.
C'est un grand chantier.
Nous, un petit groupe de militants,
avons rédigé un projet de loi pour l'ombudsman du gouvernement indien.
Les amis, vous en entendrez beaucoup parler.
C'est le mouvement que je conduis en ce moment,
et c'est le mouvement et l'ambition de ma vie.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Merci beaucoup. Merci.
Merci. Merci. Merci.